but i think if it's purely learning
you're actor that learning can be done
much more either on your own or through
the internet or by uniting through the
internet with like-minded groups um so i
think that's one problem with the
current educational system
[Music]
what's your opinion on the current
education system when i asked people on
twitter what they wanted to ask you this
question came up a couple times which
was um you know how would you fix it
what's your opinion on the education
system what are your thoughts around
that
i think there's no question it's
completely obsolete
the
education system is a path-dependent
outcome
from the need for daycare
from the need for prisons for
college-aged males who would otherwise
overrun society and cause a lot of havoc
at the original medieval universities
and guard towers that face inwards for
example
um
yeah because you you have to put a
curfew in there you need to lock up the
young uh 18 year old males before they
go out with swords and daggers and you
know create trouble
so
college and schools and what the way we
think about them they come from a time
period when books were rare knowledge
was rare um
babysitting was rare
crime was common violence was prevalent
there was no such self-guided learning
so i think schools are just byproducts
of these kinds of institutions and now
we have
the internet which is the greatest web
of knowledge ever created completely
interconnected so it's very very easy to
learn if you actually have the desire to
learn everything that's on the internet
you can go on khan academy you can get
mit and yale lectures online you can get
all the coursework and get interactivity
you can read blogs by brilliant people
you can read all these great books so
it's so the ability to learn the the
means of learning the tools of learning
are abundant and infinite it's a desire
to learn that's incredibly scarce
so i don't i just don't think that
schools matter for self-motivated
students what the schools matter for is
wanted to keep the kids out of the
parents hair while the parents go to
work
it creates socialization because kids
want to be around their peers and they
want to learn how to operate society of
their peers
but i think if it's purely learning
you're after that learning can be done
much more either on your own or through
the internet or by uniting through the
internet with like-minded groups
so i think that's one problem with the
current educational system the second
problem is what do you choose to learn
and the current educational system has
to have a one-size-fits-all model has to
say well you have to learn x now and
then you have to learn why
and you know to give you examples of
where this is obsolete memorization
right in a day and age of google and
smartphones memorization is obsolete why
should you be memorizing the battle
trafalgar why you should be memorizing
what the capital of this or that state
is but we still put undue weight on that
just because that's the way it's always
been done and we've lived in a
pre-google world
um another example is how when we're
moving along at a certain pace i'm sure
ev
not everyone but i'm sure 90 of your
listeners have had this happen to them
which is they were learning mathematics
and at some point they were they were
keeping up they were doing arithmetic
and they were doing geometry they did
trigonometry then they pre-calculated
the calc and somewhere in there they got
lost
somewhere in there while building the
massive edifice the logical structure
that mathematics is they missed one
lesson they missed one concept they
missed five classes or they just didn't
they just their brain couldn't think a
certain way that something was being
explained to them it should have been
explained visually but it was being
explained numerically or it should have
been explained symbolically uh and it
was being explained in cartography but
what have you but they were not able to
keep up and the moment you lose that
wrong in mathematics the moment you miss
that wrong on the ladder you can't go to
the next one because now the next one
the teacher's like okay we're done with
pre-calculus now we're moving on to
calculus you're saying wait i didn't
understand pre-calculus and i understand
how pre-calculus leads from trigonometry
to calculus i missed that whole part so
now you get the calculus you don't
understand the fundamentals and now you
reduce the memorization so now you're
like okay dxdy when i see that symbol i
do this but now you've lost the actual
learning you've lost the connection to
the underlying principles so i think
learning should be about learning the
basics in all the fields and learning
them really well over and over because
life is mostly about applying the basics
and only doing the advanced stuff in the
things that you truly love and where you
understand the basics inside out but
that's not how our
system is built we teach all these kids
calculus and they walk out not
understanding calculus at all when
really they would have been better off
served just doing arithmetic and basic
computer programming the entire time
so i i think there's a there's a pace of
learning issue and then there's finally
a
what to learn and there's a whole set of
things we don't even bother trying to
teach we don't teach
nutrition we don't teach cooking we
don't teach how to be in happy positive
relationships we don't teach how to keep
your body healthy and fit you know we
just say sports
we don't teach
happiness we don't teach meditation
maybe we shouldn't teach some of these
things
different kids will have different
aptitudes but maybe we should maybe we
should teach practical uh construction
of technology and
and uh
you know maybe everyone in their science
project instead of building a little
chemistry volcano maybe you should be
building a smartphone
right
so we just haven't kept up
and i have to believe that we can change
the system but we're not but you never
you never change a system by taking the
existing thing and reworking it i don't
believe i've been in silicon valley in
tech business long enough to know that
you're better off changing it just by
creating something brand new so one
fantasy idea i've had is you know after
i'm done with angel list or if i have
more time with my hands i would like to
create a successor to the uh one laptop
project uh in mit nicholas negroponte
had the one laptop for a child project
uh but then i saw this fascinating
write-up and this is a really long time
ago maybe even five years ago maybe it
was an economist or somewhere it was a
story about how
they left a box full of unopened android
tablets in a little village in pakistan
and when they came back months later uh
the kids have opened the box they've all
figured out how to boot up the tablets
they're hacked them they've gotten past
the user administration login they've
installed a whole bunch of apps they've
got a little economy set up the older
kids are teaching the younger kids
they're teaching their grandmothers how
to run businesses they're surfing the
web they've taught themselves in english
you know kids are learning machines they
just need the tools
so to that end what i would love to do
is create a very low cost very rugged
easily powered cheap android tablet
that's hard to destroy
and basically distribute them around the
world with pre-built learning
applications so that you can literally
fire one up and it works with you
interactively in 30 seconds and figures
out what language do you speak if any or
just be symbolic and what level of
aptitude are you at are you a second
grader third grade or fifth grader and
of course it varies by different
discipline and then let you dive into
and let you
learn anything you want that will make
your life better just going back to just
my competency
exactly and it always keeps you on the
edge and it always keeps pushing you and
then you can network in all the teachers
of the world so anyone who wants to be a
teacher can contributes not just salman
khan doing khan academy but essentially
you could network connect all the
teachers of the world and all the
students of the world
using tablets and do it at a pace and
level where it's essentially customized
for each child and they're learning the
things that have a practical outcome in
their life and i know there's advantage
of liberal arts education pushing things
that people aren't don't necessarily
want to learn on their own but
they have to have some desire for it
it's better to wait until they think
they're ready and then give it all to
them
because i think that's the way that
learning sticks so that's that's the
kind of project i like to work on but i
don't i don't think it's solvable with
the current school system i hope you get
a chance to work on that i think that'd
be a phenomenal impact to the world yeah
i think i think it would be fun and and
i'm thinking about this now more because
i have a young infant son and
i honestly i don't want to send him to
school how do you as an adult i mean you
mentioned a couple physics books in in
the the start of the the interview here
how do you as an adult go about learning
new subjects you specifically and yeah
mostly i just stay on the basics so even
when i'm learning physics
or science i'm sticking to the basics
so i'll read concepts for fun
but i'm more likely to
you know do something that is arithmetic
than calculus i'm not going to be a
great physicist at this point maybe in
the next lifetime or when my kid will do
it
but it's too late for me so i i have to
stick to what i enjoy and what i love
about science is
mathematics is the language of nature
sciences to me is a study of truth um it
is the only true discipline because it
makes falsifiable predictions it
actually changes the world
and applied science becomes technology
and technology is what separates us from
the animals and allows us to have things
like cell phones and houses and cars and
heat and electricity
so science to me the study of truth and
mathematics is the language of science
and nature um so in that sense i'm not
religious but i'm spiritual and to me
that is the most devotional thing that i
could do to study the laws of the
universe um and so the same kick that
you know some guy might get out of being
in mecca or medina and you know bowing
to
uh you know the prophet i get that same
feeling of awe
and that same small sense of self when i
study science
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
you